I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello and welcome back to Office Ladies. This week we are breaking down the job part two. It's the season three finale second half written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Shore, directed by Ken Quapas. Last week, we interviewed Paul Lieberstein, aka Toby, about this episode. It was great. So fun. So fun to talk to him. Well, this week we're going to break down the second half. And I've got a summary to catch
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好，欢迎回到办公室女郎。本周我们要剖析的是《工作（下）》。这是第三季季终集的下半部分，由保罗·利伯斯坦和迈克·肖尔编剧，肯·夸帕斯执导。上周，我们采访了保罗·利伯斯坦（也就是托比），聊了聊这一集。太棒了。太有趣了。和他聊天真开心。好吧，这周我们要剖析下半部分，我准备了一份摘要来帮大家
us up. Well, Jenna, you know, I can't wait to hear it. So I know. Now, do you really like my summaries, Angela? Or is this? I actually really do. Now, that probably sounded like I was being some BFF sass to you. But I actually really do because you're so good at summarizing them. I think you might have missed your calling as like someone who writes the caption for movies, you know, like the little slogan comes up on your TV guide. Yes. Yes. I think you could have been that person, except for look who's talking. That made me laugh out loud. I know, I got you. Okay, so give us a summary.
回顾剧情。好吧，珍娜，你知道的，我迫不及待想听了。我知道。安吉拉，你真的很喜欢我的摘要吗？还是说？我其实真的很喜欢。刚才听起来可能我有点在跟你这位好闺蜜开玩笑。但我确实真心觉得你太擅长写摘要了。我觉得你可能本来可以胜任电影简介撰写人之类的工作，你知道的，就像电视指南上那种简短的宣传语。对。对。我觉得你完全可以干这个，不过看我这话说的。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。我知道，我懂你。好吧，那就给我们讲讲摘要吧。
All right. Last week, we discussed how Michael got back together with Jan after she revealed her breast enhancement. He named Dwight as his successor to Dunder Mifflin, because he was so sure he was going to get this job at corporate. But I have just pause one second here. Is that even Michael's decision to make? We did not talk about this. I mean, if Michael gets the job at corporate, is he allowed to just say who gets the manager job at Dunder Mifflin Scranton? No, no, absolutely not. I'm sure that's like a corporate decision, where they like have an overview of all and you know, all the employees, I'm sure Michael gets to put in his recommendation as someone that worked in that branch. But ultimately, that would be David Wallace's
好的。上周我们讨论了迈克尔在简公开了隆胸手术后是如何跟她复合的。他任命德怀特为他在邓德米弗林的接班人，因为他坚信自己能得到总部的工作。不过我得先暂停一下。这真的是迈克尔能决定的吗？我们之前没讨论过这个。我是说，如果迈克尔得到了总部的工作，他能随心所欲地决定谁来当邓德米弗林斯克兰分公司的经理吗？不，不，绝对不能。我敢肯定这绝对是总公司的决定，他们会统筹全局，了解所有员工。我确信迈克尔可以作为该分公司的工作人员提出建议。但最终决定权在于大卫·华莱士
decision. Thank you. I feel like we failed to discuss that last week and I needed to bring it up. Well, I got you. Done and done. All right. So also last week, Dwight interviewed Andy to be his number two and Jim and Karen left for New York. Mm hmm. This week, Ham is going to become Dwight's secret assistant to the regional manager. We will see Michael, Jim and Karen all interview for the position at corporate, and we will ultimately find out who gets the job.
手中。谢谢你。我觉得我们上周漏掉了这一点，我必须把它提出来。好吧，我懂了。说得对。好的。上周还有，德怀特面试了安迪来当他的副手，吉姆和卡伦去了纽约。嗯哼。这周，哈姆将成为德怀特的地区经理秘密助理。我们将看到迈克尔、吉姆和卡伦都参加总部职位的面试，并且最终我们会知道谁得到了这份工作。
Yes, there's some relationship stuff thrown in there, too. But you know, there's a little bit isn't there a relationship stuff. All right. Fast fact number one, fan question from Maddie Jensen. I noticed that Ken Quapas directed the finale for season three, along with the finale of season two. Both episodes are crucial to the Jim Pam plotline of the show. Was this an intentional decision to have the same director in charge of these important episodes? Or was it just a happy accident? Well, this was very intentional. I'm so glad you said that because I was sitting here and I wasn't sure I was I was like,
是的，里面还穿插了一些感情线。不过你知道的，确实有一点，不是吗，感情线。好的，第一条趣事，来自麦迪·詹森的粉丝提问。我注意到肯·夸帕斯执导了第三季的季终集，还有第二季的季终集。这两集对剧中的吉姆和帕姆感情线都至关重要。让同一个导演来掌导这些重要的剧集是刻意安排的，还是只是一次美好的意外？嗯，这绝对是刻意安排的。我很高兴你这么说，因为我刚才坐在这儿，心里还挺不确定的，我在想，
what is she going to say? And I was like, I hope it was thought out because Ken was so caring about the different dynamics and relationships on the show. He had been with us since the pilot. We had such a trust for his vision. And if you were about to say, it was just a scheduling thing, I was going to be like, no. No, I traded some emails with Kent Zabornak, and he told me that he and Greg always wanted Ken Quapas to direct milestone episodes. So season openers, season closers, or any episodes with big story movement, especially if they involve Jim and Pam, he wasn't always available. But that was the intention. And if you look back, and you'll see that oftentimes it was
她会怎么说呢？我在想，我希望这是深思熟虑过的，因为肯非常关心剧中不同的动态和人物关系。他从试播集开始就一直和我们在一起。我们对他的愿景有着极大的信任。如果你刚才要说这只是排片日程的安排，我就会说，才不是呢。我跟肯特·扎博纳克发了几封邮件，他告诉我，他和格Greg一直都希望肯·夸帕斯来执导具有里程碑意义的剧集。比如季首集、季终集，或者任何有重大剧情发展的剧集，特别是那些涉及吉姆和帕姆的剧集。他虽然不总是腾得出时间，但这就是他们的初衷。如果你回看过去，你会发现通常都是
Ken Quapas, Greg Daniels, Paul Feig or Paul Lieberstein, who would direct these big milestone episodes, which makes sense because those guys were kind of the original team of visionaries for the show. And they were with us since the first season. Yeah. So they knew every character's journey. And I think that was super important. That was sometimes a learning curve for new directors. If they hadn't seen every single episode, they would come in and maybe not understand why a character was making a certain choice. And I remember the cast would sometimes just bring them up to speed. Oh, I did. I remember I was in the scene. I forget who the director was, but they were like, so let's
肯·夸帕斯、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、保罗·菲格或保罗·利伯斯坦来执导这些具有重大里程碑意义的剧集，这很合情合理，因为这几个人可以说是该剧最初的远见者团队。他们从第一季开始就和我们在一起了。是的。所以他们了解每个角色的心路历程。我觉得这超级重要。对于新导演来说，有时会有一个学习曲线。如果他们没有看过每一集，他们来的时候可能就不会理解为什么某个角色会做出某种选择。我记得演员有时会直接给他们恶补一下背景。哦，我想起来了。我记得我当时在那场戏里。我忘了导演是谁，但他们说，那么让
have Angela over there like cutting the meat or something. It was like a party episode. And I was like, oh, she wouldn't touch that meat. She's vegetarian. She wouldn't. She wouldn't go near it. Yes. And they're like, oh, okay, I guess I'll put you over there by the bag of chips. I'm like, yes, that's better. Exactly. So this created a really nice sense of consistency for those big episodes to bring people back who knew us all so well. All right. Fast fact. Number two, this is a fan question from Beatrix Smith, Brooke B, Amelia C, Erica P, and Supa Nanduri. Did the conversation at the beach between Jim and Pam that we see throughout this episode? Did it have to be recreated like the kiss on Casino Night? Or was it a
安吉拉去那边切肉或者干点别的吧。那是一场派对场景。我说，哦，她才不会碰那块肉。她是素食主义者。她不会的。她才不会靠近它。是的。然后他们说，哦，好吧，那我把你安排在薯片袋旁边吧。我说，对，这样好多了。没错。所以，对于这些重磅剧集来说，找回对我们如此熟悉的人，为这些重要的剧集创造了一种非常好的连贯性。好的。第二条趣事，这是一个来自贝atrix·史密斯、布鲁克·B、阿米莉亚·C、艾瑞卡·P和苏帕·南杜里的粉丝提问。我们在这一整集中看到的吉姆和帕姆在海滩上的对话，是像《赌场之夜》里的吻那样必须重新拍摄的吗？还是说，
deleted scene that was added later without audio? What's the story? Well, guys, this was a new scene. But we knew about it when we were shooting beach games. So we shot this during the beach games shoot. We did not have to go back to the dam. Oh, yeah, we couldn't get that location again. So they shot it while we were there. And Jenna, I remember that they brought Ken Quapas to direct that. So and that was actually very common. That wasn't like anything weird to Harold Ramis. That was really common on a show if you had a crossboard moment where you had a scene that was in another episode, the director of that episode would come and direct that to sort of complete their story. So Ken came back and Jenna, I read
这原本是一个被删掉的场景，后来在没有音频的情况下被加进去了？这背后有什么故事？好吧，各位，这是一个新场景。但我们在拍摄《海滩游戏》时就知道这件事了。所以我们是在拍摄《海滩游戏》期间顺便拍了这一幕。我们不需要再回到那个水坝去。哦，对，我们没办法再次租下那个取景地了。所以他们在那里的时候就顺便拍了。而且珍娜，我记得他们请来了肯·夸帕斯来执导那场戏。所以，这其实很常见。对哈罗德·雷米斯来说这没什么奇怪的。在一部剧中，如果你有一个跨场景的时刻，也就是某个场景属于另一集，那一集的导演就会过来执导那一幕，以便把他们的故事补充完整。所以肯回来了，珍娜，我读到
that this was supposed to be in the beginning of the show, like the cold open. Yes, just like that jump from Casino Night to Gay Witch Hunt, we were going to originally open this episode. The cold open was going to be watching this scene between Jim and Pam on the beach. I'm so glad it wasn't that way. I think it creates so much more tension. Yeah. To leave it until later as a flashback. And you know, Jenna, it really did add to the tension because now we know as the audience that they had had this moment. And so when Pam is saying goodbye and good luck and all of that, it's layered with this moment that they shared at Beach Games. And I love that our show did this. Our show didn't always just spoon feed
过，这本来应该放在剧集开头，也就是开场白里的。没错，就像从《赌场之夜》到《同性恋万圣节》的跳跃一样，我们原本打算用这个开场。开场白本来是播放吉姆和帕姆在海滩上的这段对话。我很庆幸最后没这么拍。我觉得这样处理制造了更多的张力。对。把它留到后面作为倒叙。而且你知道吗，珍娜，这确实增强了戏剧张力，因为作为观众，我们现在知道他们有过这样一段时刻。所以当帕姆说再见、祝你好运以及所有这些话时，都叠加了他们俩在《海滩游戏》中分享的那段回忆。我太喜欢我们剧集的这种处理方式了。我们的剧集并不总是直接把剧情喂给
the audience. It just had them like sort of pick up in the middle. And I just loved it. Me too. Me too. It was during the editing process that they decided to take it out of the cold open and put it later. Dave Rogers said in the DVD commentary that it was Mike Scher's idea to make it a flashback later in the episode. I love that. I know. He's so smart. He's such a smarty. Fast fact number three, Angela, I'm staying consistent today. It is a fan question from Faye B, Kayla Moffitt, Tiffany L, Breanna K, and Rowena C. Did John and Rashida actually film in New York and how much of the crew was with them? Yeah, guys. Yeah. They went to New York for one day of filming. We were so envious whenever anyone
观众。而是让他们自己去体会中间发生的事。我太喜欢了。我也是。我也是。是在剪辑过程中，他们决定把它从开场白中拿掉，放到后面去。戴夫·罗杰斯在DVD评论音轨中说过，把它作为剧集后半部分的闪回是迈克·谢尔的主意。我喜欢这个主意。我知道。他太聪明了。他真是个小机灵鬼。第三条趣事，安吉拉，我今天保持了一贯的风格。这是一个来自费伊·B、凯拉·莫菲特、蒂芙尼·L、布里安娜·K和罗威纳·C的粉丝提问。约翰和拉什达真的在纽约实地拍摄了吗？有多少剧组人员跟着他们一起去了？是的，各位。是的。他们去纽约拍了一天。每当有人能去别的地方时，我们都羡慕得要死，因为我们从来没机会去进行大旅行，不过这次去的是一个精简剧组。他们去了纽约。
got to go anywhere because we, we never got to go on big trips, but this was a skeleton crew. And they went to New York. Yeah, we actually wrapped filming in Los Angeles on March 28th, 2007. They did not go to New York to pick up the Jim and Karen scenes until April 19th of 2007. So we had been wrapped for the season for a little while. Wow, I didn't know that. That was from Kentopedia. Of course, he's going to give us those details. He's Kentopedia. Well, the people who went were Greg, Paul, Mike, Sher, Kent, Randall, RDP, our camera assistant, Chris Workman, and our sound mixer, Ben. Now, they talked about this a little bit on the DVD commentary about how they had to sort of do that gorilla
是的，我们实际上是在2007年3月28日结束了洛杉矶的拍摄。直到2007年4月19日，他们才去纽约补拍吉姆和帕姆的镜头。所以当时我们已经杀青一段时间了。哇，我不知道这件事。那是来自“肯托百科”的爆料。他当然会给我们提供这些细节了。他可是“肯托百科”啊。好吧，去的人有格雷格、保罗、迈克·谢尔、肯、兰德尔、RDP（我们的摄影助理）、克里斯·沃克曼（我们的录音师本）。现在，他们在DVD评论音轨里简单聊过他们是如何进行那种游击式
shooting, you know, like they were sort of sneaking around filming in little spots where they could. And John jokingly called Greg, covert Greg, because like Greg, Greg would have a note, but he wouldn't want to talk directly to him. So he'd be like, like he would act like he was passing by, or he would send Kent Sabornak with his kid. Kent's kid was with them. And they would walk across the street and nonchalantly kind of tell John a note. And then so it looked like they were just people, pedestrians in Manhattan. Amazing. Because they, I guess they didn't want people to notice that they were filming because all those people became background people. They didn't want to draw attention to John and
拍摄的，你知道的，就像他们偷偷摸摸地在能找到的小地方拍摄一样。约翰开玩笑地称格雷格为“秘密格雷格”，因为格雷格会有意见，但他又不想直接跟约翰说。所以他会装作路过，或者他会派肯特·扎博纳克带着他的孩子去。肯特的儿子也跟他们在一起。他们会穿过街道，若无其事地把意见告诉约翰。这样看起来他们就只是曼哈顿的普通路人。太神奇了。因为他们，我猜他们不想让人们注意到他们在拍电影，因为所有那些人后来都成了背景路人。他们不想把注意力吸引到约翰和
Rashida, I guess. They had seen what happened when people like realized Steve was being filmed, right? Yeah. Well, they had a tight day. Kent told me they filmed in nine different locations around New York City, all in that one day. And they hired a local crew to fill out the production for hair, makeup, wardrobe grips, electric drivers, craft service and set production assistance. They had to come up with a little mini New York crew. But that's how we did it. I love it. I love it. Here's one other little piece of trivia. Rashida and John said that
拉什达身上吧。我猜是这样。他们见识过当人们意识到史蒂夫在拍戏时会发生什么，对吧？是的。好吧，他们的时间非常紧。肯告诉我，他们那天在纽约市的不同地点一共拍了九个地方，全都在那一天完成的。他们还雇佣了当地的工作人员来负责发型、化妆、服装、场务、灯光师、司机、剧组餐饮和现场制片助理。他们不得不临时凑齐了一个小型的纽约本地剧组。但这就是我们的拍摄方式。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。这里还有另一个小趣事。拉什达和约翰说，
they wore their own clothes for all the scenes in New York City. That makes sense to me. Yeah. I also thought they looked really cute. And I was like, oh, I like Rashida has great taste and John is cute. They look like normal people, not like, you know, the Dundramiflin folks. Here's some tidbits. Ready? Okay. Kinsey tidbits. Kinsey tidbit from the DVD commentary. John said that there was like this kind of drunk
他们在纽约市的所有场景中穿的都是他们自己的衣服。这倒挺合情合理的。对。我也觉得他们看起来超级可爱。当时我想，哦，我觉得拉什达很有品位，约翰也很可爱。他们看起来就像普通人，而不是那种邓德米弗林员工的样子。这里有一些花絮。准备好了吗？好的。金西花絮。来自DVD评论音轨的金西花絮。约翰说当时在餐馆拍摄时，有个看起来像是喝醉了的
guy while they were filming in the restaurant. And he kept coming up to them and he's in a white shirt. So if you see it in 1934, there's a guy standing there sort of next to John. And he was like, what are you guys doing? And John sort of was like trying to keep it like, you know, he didn't want to draw attention to it because they were filming from like across the street, you know? Yeah. Through the window. Yeah. So he was like, oh, you know, man, we're just doing a scene. He's like, oh, you're doing a scene. You're doing a scene. He was like, buddy, come on.
家伙。他一直凑过来，而且他还穿着一件白衬衫。所以如果你在1934年（此处疑为时间码误读）看到这个画面，会看到有个家伙站在那里，挨着约翰。他当时问，你们在干什么呢？约翰就试图保持低调，你知道的，他不想引起注意，因为他们当时是从街对面拍摄的，你知道吗？对。透过窗户。对。所以约翰就说，哦，你知道的，老兄，我们只是在拍戏。那人就说，哦，你在拍戏啊。你在拍戏啊。约翰就说，老兄，行了吧。
Oh my gosh. So they were, and he said that he like, this guy like heckled them through that whole moment. That is crazy. I know. Listen, lady, should we take a quick break? And then when we come back, we can start breaking down the job part two. Yeah, let's do it. All right, we'll be right back.
天哪。所以他们当时，约翰说这个家伙在整个拍摄过程中一直在起哄挑衅。太疯狂了。我知道。听着，女士们，我们要不要休息一下？然后等我们回来，就可以开始剖析《工作（下）》了。好的，我们开始吧。好的，我们马上回来。
Okay, we are back. And Jim and Karen are arriving in New York. They're getting off the subway. And oh my God, Angela. What? Do you have a story about Astor Place? I do not. I want to know, did you see the lady with the baby stroller who gives major side eye to John and Rashida? No. Is she by as they come out of the subway station? As they come out of the subway station, there is a woman with a baby stroller. She is clearly
好了，我们回来了。吉姆和帕姆到达了纽约。他们走出了地铁站。天哪，安吉拉。什么？你有什么关于阿斯特广场的故事吗？没有。我想知道，你看到那个推着婴儿车对约翰和拉什达翻了个巨大白眼的女士了吗？没有。她就在他们走出地铁站的时候吗？就在他们走出地铁站的时候，有一个推着婴儿车的女人。她显然
not with us. Yeah. She's just a lady walking her kid. Living her life. It's at 18 minutes, 29 seconds. I need to know who this woman is. I need to hear her story. I need to see her face. I need to see it. I took a picture.
不是我们剧组的。是的。她只是一个带孩子的路人。过着她自己的生活。画面在18分29秒。我想知道这个女人是谁。我想听听她的故事。我想看看她的脸。我一定要看看。我拍了张照片。
Oh, good. Show me. Show me. We'll put it in our Insta stories, guys. Office ladies pod. Office ladies pod. Okay, lady. I found it. Here she is. She's so annoyed. I love her. She's so over it. She is so over it. Oh my gosh. So over it. Lady with stroller. Please contact us at office ladies pod. Lady with stroller. We're sorry.
哦，太好了。给我看看。给我看看。我们会把它发到我们的Ins快拍上的，各位。办公室女郎播客。办公室女郎播客。好的，女士。我找到了。她在这儿。她看起来太烦躁了。我太喜欢她了。她已经受够了。她真的受够了。天哪。简直烦透了。推婴儿车的女士。请通过 office ladies pod 联系我们。推婴儿车的女士。我们很抱歉。
Yes. Please email us at officeladiesatearwolf.com. What is she going to say? She's prominently featured in an episode of the office. Is she an office fan? What does she remember about that day? Did she recognize them? Because her response is like, who are these guys? Well, Jenna, she wasn't the only one who was ticked off that day because at 20 minutes, 34 seconds, there is a girl and clearly like a party dress and she's hailing a cab. She was not an extra. And I guess they had to make her stop hailing her cab because she
是的。请给我们发邮件至 officeladies@earwolf.com。她会说些什么呢？她在《办公室》的一集中有这么醒目的镜头。她是一个办公室粉丝吗？她对那天有什么印象？她认出他们了吗？因为她的反应就像是，这群人是谁啊？好吧，珍娜，那天觉得不爽的可不止她一个，因为在20分钟34秒的时候，有一个女孩，穿着明显像是派对礼服的衣服，在路边叫出租车。她可不是群演。我猜他们不得不让她停止叫车，因为她的镜头
was so featured and sign a release and she was really annoyed because she like Mr. Cab or something. They talk about it on the DVD commentary. She was like, I just, you know, I'm sure she's like, I just want to go to my party. What are these forms? Maybe she's like me, Jenna, she doesn't like a lot of forms. Okay. Woman with baby stroller, woman hailing a cab, email us and party dress in a party dress. We want to hear from you. Okay. Before we move on, I have a little mini deep dive. Please. Okay. So Jenna, at 1943, Jim mentions that he went to a bar that used to be a church and I was like, I know exactly
太突出了，必须让她签一份肖像授权书，而且她当时真的很生气，因为她好像错过了出租车什么的。他们在DVD评论音轨里聊过这件事。她当时就说，我只是，你知道的，我敢肯定她的意思就是，我只想去参加我的派对。这些表格是什么鬼？也许她跟我一样，珍娜，她不喜欢填一堆表格。好吧。推婴儿车的女人，叫出租车的女人，给我们发邮件吧，还有穿派对礼服的女孩。我们想听到你们的声音。好吧，在我们继续之前，我有一个微型深度剖析。请讲。
what they're talking about. What? The limelight. Remember? I don't know the limelight. No, I don't know this place. It's on 6th Avenue. Okay. So when I was interning on Conan O'Brien, you guys, I was, you know, I was a bit of a sad sack. I never went out. New York was so expensive. I didn't know anyone. And a gal I worked with, Debbie Wunder, kind of took me under her wing and she was like,
好的。那么珍娜，在19分43秒，吉姆提到他去了一家以前是教堂的酒吧，当时我就想，我太知道他们在说什么了。什么？灵光酒吧（The Limelight）。还记得吗？我不知道灵光酒吧。不，我不知道这个地方。它在第六大道上。好吧。所以当我在柯南·奥布莱恩节目组实习的时候，各位，我当时（你知道的）有点像个倒霉蛋。我从来不出门。纽约太贵了。我谁也不认识。然后一个跟我一起工作的姑娘，黛比·翁德尔，有点像把我当妹妹一样罩着她，她就说，
Angela, you got to get out. I was like, wha. And she said, there's a great band we're going to go listen to tonight. Jen, I'm pretty sure I wore my gap denim dress on some kids because I knew what New York fashion looks like. Oh, yeah. We show up. By the way, I went with Debbie and her boyfriend, So High Third Wheel. We show up to where the band is playing and it is inside a Gothic cathedral that is a bar. And Debbie's like, this is a famous New York bar. And I'm like, lady, that's a church. I can't go inside it because I'll get in trouble with my mom. You can't have a bar in a church.
安吉拉，你得出去走走。我说，啊。她说，今晚有一支很棒的乐队，我们要去听。珍娜，我敢肯定我当时穿的是我的Gap牛仔裙，搭配某些鞋子，因为我知道纽约时尚长什么样。哦，耶。我们到了。顺便说一句，我是跟黛比还有她的男朋友一起去的，妥妥的超大型电灯泡。我们到了乐队演出的大地方，结果它竟然是在一个哥特式大教堂里面，那是个酒吧。黛比就说，这是纽约著名的酒吧。我说，大姐，那是个教堂。我可不能进去，不然我妈会饶不了我的。你怎么能在教堂里开酒吧呢？
Yes you can. And this church has the most cool, amazing story. Okay. I'm going to walk you through it really quickly. So it was built in 1844. It was this Gothic revival church. Huge, beautiful structure. It looked like a medieval church, like from England, you know. And it has the main big church, right? I'm talking cathedral ceilings, the big stained glass. Oh, yeah. It's got a rectory. It's got a sister's house for the nuns. It's got a parish house, a chapel and a garden courtyard. This is huge. Wait, wait. Is this the one on 6th Avenue with the red door?
当然可以。而且这个教堂有着极其酷炫惊人的历史。好吧。我简单给你讲讲。它建于1844年。这是一个哥特复兴式教堂。巨大、美丽的建筑。看起来像中世纪的教堂，就像英国那种，你知道的。它有主教堂，对吧？我说的是大教堂的天花板，巨大的彩色玻璃。哦，是的。它有神职人员住所。有为修女准备的修女院。它还有一个教区住宅、一个小礼拜堂和一个花园庭院。这规模太大了。等等，等等。这是第六大道上那个有红门的吗？
Yes. Yes. I do know what you're talking about. Okay. It's beautiful, right? It's beautiful. Okay. So I guess, you know, it was a very happening church for a long time. But then in the 60s, the neighborhood kind of took a turn. People started moving out to the suburbs. All of a sudden, this big, gothic structure, you know, it was hard to maintain the heating and the repairs and all of that. So they had to sort of repurpose it. At first, they made it into a cultural center and that sort of went on for a bit. That makes sense, right? Cultural center. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。我知道你在说什么了。好吧。它很美，对吧？很美。好吧。所以我想，你知道的，它曾是一个很热闹的教堂，维持了很长时间。但到了60年代，社区情况有点变了。人们开始搬到郊区去。突然之间，这座宏伟的哥特式建筑，你知道的，要维持暖气和维修等等费用变得很困难。所以他们不得不改变它的用途。起初，他们把它改成了一个文化中心，这维持了一段时间。这很合理，对吧？文化中心。是的。是的。
They couldn't keep up with the cost of running the place. So this famous sort of New York like bar owner bought it and people were furious. They were like, you cannot make this church a bar. You can't. Well, he did. And he like tricked it all out. Like he made the sister's house, I guess, into like the shampoo room, you know, like where you get shampoo room. I didn't know what it was either. But I guess that's like a party where you get sprayed with foam. I don't know. It sounds horrible. I know. I would get it in my eyes. How can you not? But he made it this big, big, like hipster bar scene. Andy Warhol opened it up
他们负担不起运营这个地方的成本了。于是这个纽约著名的酒吧老板买下了它，人们气炸了。他们觉得，你们怎么能把这个教堂变成酒吧呢？你们不能这么做。好吧，他不仅这么做了，还把里里外外彻底改装了一番。比如他把修女院改成了泡沫派对室（shampoo room），你知道的，就是那种会被喷满泡沫的地方。我以前也不知道那是什么。但我想那就像是一个会向你喷泡沫的派对。听起来太可怕了。我知道。泡沫会弄进我眼睛里的。怎么会不进呢？但他把它打造成了一个超级火爆的嬉皮士酒吧场景。安迪·沃霍尔在开业周末
on the opening weekend. It was like this big place for music and events from the 80s through the 90s. Then in the 90s, I guess things took a turn. I think crime got bad again. And lady, this party promoter named Michael Alec murdered and dismembered this guy at the limelight. What? Yeah. He murdered a guy. And so then they're like, okay, they close it down. Then they try to like give it a new reopening. They call it the Avalon in 2003. That doesn't really work. People are like, done. They're like, you know, get your bar out of the church. We're done. 2007, it permanently closed its doors, which is interesting to me because
还来捧过场。从80年代到90年代，这里成了音乐和活动的大热场所。然后到了90年代，我猜情况急转直下。我记得犯罪率又变高了。然后呢，一个名叫迈克尔·亚历克的派对策划人在灵光酒吧谋杀并肢解了一个人。什么？是的。他谋杀了一个人。于是后来，他们决定把这里关闭。接着他们试图重新开业。他们在2003年把它叫做阿瓦隆（Avalon）。这并没有真正成功。人们的态度是：够了。他们就觉得，你知道的，把你的酒吧从教堂里搬出去吧。我们受够了。2007年，它永远关门大吉了，这让我觉得很有意思，因为
we filmed this in 2007. Wow. Yeah. Them mentioning that they went to this bar, if we had filmed the following year, they couldn't have done it. Yeah. I think the writers all knew about this bar, right? It was famous, a bar inside of a gothic church, right? All the writers knew about it, I think. But here's the interesting thing. Guess what it is today? Not a bar. You're not going to be able to guess. What is it?
我们拍摄这一集正是在2007年。哇。是的。他们提到去过这家酒吧，如果我们是第二年拍摄的，他们就去不成了。是的。我想编剧们都知道这家酒吧吧？它很有名，一个开在哥特式教堂里的酒吧，对吧？我想所有的编剧都知道。但有趣的是，你猜猜它今天是做什么的？不是酒吧。你绝对猜不到。是什么？
Well, first of all, the people that bought it restored all of it. It really meant a lot to them to restore the integrity of the structure, the stained glass, but it is partly a gym called the Complete Body Limelight, so you can lift weights inside the church. And then the chapel is a modern dim sum restaurant called Julan Club. So you can go work out and then get some dim sum. Let's do it. Let's do it. I love that. I just found it fascinating because as soon as he said that, Jenna, what do I ever know about any bars or pop culture stuff? Never. Never.
首先，买下它的人把里面全修复了。修复建筑的完整性、彩色玻璃，对他们来说意义重大。但它现在一部分是一个叫做“完全体灵光”的健身房，所以你可以在教堂里举铁。然后小礼拜堂变成了一个名为朱兰俱乐部的现代点心餐厅。所以你可以去锻炼，然后再去吃点心。我们去吧。我们去吧。我太喜欢了。我只是觉得这太迷人了，因为当他说出那句话时，珍娜，我什么时候了解过任何酒吧或流行文化的东东？从来没有。从来没有。
Never. You know nothing about them. Not only did I know, but I had been there. That's pretty badass. I know. I went with Debbie and her boyfriend at the time who was a exterminator. Oh. Yeah. And Debbie, it's okay if I say this right. In the cab ride home, you and him started making out and I had to sit awkwardly looking out the window.
你对这些一无所知。我不仅知道，我还去过那里。这可真是太酷了。我知道。我是和黛比以及她当时那个当除虫师的男朋友一起去的。哦。是的。黛比，我说这个应该没关系吧。在回家的出租车上，你和他在后座亲热起来，我只能尴尬地看着窗外。
That sounds like they had a good time. They had a great time. Mom, I'm sorry I went to a bar that was inside a church. Mom, I'm sorry. Well, listen, Ange, also during this talking head, Jim says that they think they saw Lorne Michaels. Yeah. And we got a lot of fan questions about that from Angela A. Alley S. Kirsten O. Tyler N. Heather C. And many more all want to know is the man that walks behind Jim Lorne Michaels?
听起来他们度过了一段美好的时光。他们度过了非常美好的时光。妈妈，对不起，我去了开在教堂里的酒吧。妈妈，对不起。好吧，听着，安吉，还有在这个面对镜头独白（Talking Head）的场景中，吉姆说他们觉得自己看到了洛恩·迈克尔斯。对。我们收到了很多关于这的粉丝提问，来自安吉拉·A、艾莉·S、克尔斯滕·O、泰勒·N、希瑟·C以及许多其他人，他们都想知道，从吉姆身后走过的那个人是洛恩·迈克尔斯吗？
Was that a little cameo joke? No. No. It's not Lorne Michaels. I zoomed in. It's definitely, definitely not Lorne Michaels. I like to think that Jim is someone who thinks he recognizes famous people places, but they're just, just normal folks. I feel like, I feel like my sister Tina does that. You know, she'd be like, that's Angelina Jolie. I'm like, why would Angelina Jolie be in the mall in our hometown right now?
那是一个小客串彩蛋吗？不是。绝对不是。那不是洛恩·迈克尔斯。我放大看过了。绝对、绝对不是洛恩·迈克尔斯。我倾向于认为吉姆就是那种觉得自己能在某些地方认出名人，但其实他们只是普通人的人。我觉得，我觉得我姐姐蒂娜就会这样。你知道的，她会说，那是安吉丽娜·朱莉。我说，安吉丽娜·朱莉现在为什么会出现在我们家乡的购物中心里？
Yes, exactly. You know, another thing that happens here is that Karen kind of confronts Jim. Yeah. And she says, what is going to happen to our relationship if one of us gets this job? If I get this job, will you move to New York to be with me? And Jim is clearly uncomfortable. He's making jokes. He's trying to make jokes. Yeah. But Karen brings it around and she's like, actually I'm, I'm kind of serious. Like after what happened on the beach, do I have a future with you? Because I don't feel like I have a future in Scranton, but I'd like to have a future with you.
对，完全如此。你知道的，这里发生的另一件事是卡伦质问了吉姆。对。她说，如果我们俩中有一个人得到了这份工作，我们的关系会变成什么样？如果我得到了这份工作，你会搬到纽约来陪我吗？而吉姆明显很不自在。他在开玩笑。他试图打哈哈。对。但卡伦把话题拉了回来，她说，其实我，我有点认真的。就像在海滩上发生的事情之后，我和你还有未来吗？因为我觉得我在斯克兰顿没有未来，但我希望能和你有一个未来。
Well, she just says there's one too many people in Scranton. Yeah. You know, she was like, I was at the beach and I don't know. He just sort of jokes it off and then grabs her hand and they cross the street and I'm sure deep down she knows that, that he's on the fence. She's got to know it. She's trying to practice good self-care. She is trying to take care of herself here. She's being assertive, but then she's not really reading the signals, which I think are super clear. You don't ever read them when you don't want to see them though. That's true. Put that
好吧，她只是说斯克兰顿有太多人了。对。你知道的，她说我在海滩上经历过那些，我不知道。他只是把这当玩笑敷衍过去，然后拉起她的手过马路，我敢肯定她内心深处知道，他现在还在摇摆不定。她肯定知道。她正在努力进行自我关怀。她在这里努力照顾好自己。她表现得很自信，但实际上她并没有真正解读那些信号，我觉得那些信号已经超级明显了。当你不想看到的时候，你永远也读不懂那些信号。没错。把这句话
on a t-shirt. All right. So now it's the next morning and it's interview time. Karen, Jim and Michael are waiting in the lobby. I should own the fact since I was snarky about the lobby, just having a bunch of brown sticks, that there is also a big plant on the other side of it, a big potted plant, everyone. Hey, a little bit of green in the corner. There you go. Well, that is nice. It is nice. And I'm sorry. I was so snarky about your big brown sticks. Well, back at Dunder Mifflin, Dwight has appointed Andy as his number two officially and Andy has accepted.
印在T恤上吧。好吧。现在是第二天早上了，面试时间到了。卡伦、吉姆和迈克尔在休息室等候。我得承认，既然我之前对休息室只有一堆棕色木棍进行了冷嘲热讽，那么其实在另一边还有一大株植物，一株很大的盆栽植物，各位。嘿，角落里终于有一点绿色了。这就对了。好吧，这挺不错的。确实挺不错的。我很抱歉。我之前对你那些巨大的棕色木棍冷嘲热讽来着。好吧，回到邓德米弗林，德怀特正式任命安迪为他的副手，安迪也接受了。
And Jenna, we do that really cool thing, except now it's Dwight where we start on him and we reveal Andy in the corner. Yes. You know that's my favorite thing. I know. I know. Andy has this talking head and it's at 21 minutes, 54 seconds. He's saying, you know, three months ago I was a Cornell grad in anger management, but look at me now and he's washing out, you know, Dwight's mug. Jenna, can you hear that sink? Yeah. I couldn't not laugh because you and I know it's a fake sink and it had that weird tinny
而且珍娜，我们拍了那个非常酷的镜头，只不过这次换成了德怀特，镜头从他开始，然后移开露出了角落里的安迪。是的。你知道那是我的最爱。我知道。我知道。安迪有一段面对镜头的独白，在21分54秒。他说，你知道的，三个月前我还是康奈尔大学毕业生，还在上情绪管理课，但看看现在的我，他正在清洗，你知道的，德怀特的马克杯。珍娜，你能听到那个水槽的声音吗？对。我忍不住笑出来，因为你和我知道那是假水槽，而且它有一种奇怪的空洞金属
sound because the water was going underneath into a bucket. Yes. They had a little pump that would pump water through that faucet, but then it just came down the drain into a bucket. Yeah. There's no plumbing there. And then it would recycle. There's no plumbing. That's right. They would set it up and take it away. So something you could not do is improvise turning on the sink because nothing would come out or pour anything down the drain because it would just
声音，因为水流直接流到底下的一个桶里了。是的。他们有一个小水泵把水抽到那个水龙头里，但水流出来之后直接顺着下水道流进了一个水桶里。对。那里根本没有接管道。而且水还会循环利用。根本没有管道。没错。他们用完就会把它搬走。所以你绝对做不到的一件事就是即兴表演打开水龙头，因为什么都不会流出来，或者把什么东西倒进下水道里，因为那只会
hit the ground. Correct. Correct. Well, now we have the scene where Dwight pulls Pam aside. He explains he's very impressed by her co-walk and he would like her to be his secret assistant to the regional manager and she accepts everything about the scene was delightful. I loved every single thing about it. I loved Dwight's bravado and Pam's just like, uh-huh, uh-huh, like what an idiot, but I'm going to go along with it. Well, I think this is her way of staying connected to Jim. He's all the way in New York,
直接流到地上。没错。没错。好吧，现在是德怀特把帕姆拉到一边的场景。他解释说他对帕姆的共同工作（co-walk）印象深刻，他希望她能成为他的地区经理秘密助理，而她答应了。这个场景的一切都太令人愉悦了。我喜欢里面的每一个细节。我喜欢德怀特的虚张声势，还有帕姆那种“嗯哼，嗯哼，就像个白痴一样，但我还是陪你演下去吧”的表情。好吧，我觉得这是她与吉姆保持联系的一种方式。他远在纽约，
but she has this talking head where she says she learned from Jim, if Dwight ever asks you to accept something in secret, you reply, absolutely I do. So I think throughout this whole episode when Pam is doing this little bit with Dwight, she is imagining how she's going to get to tell Jim all about it. Oh, for sure. For sure. Well, here's Dwight's team as he sees it. Dwight is the regional manager. Dwight is also the assistant regional manager. Andy is his number two because it's political. Pam is the secret assistant to their regional manager. And guess what? In a deleted scene, we find out that Angela is the spy in charge of the secret assistant
但她有一段面对镜头的独白，她说她从吉姆那里学到了，如果德怀特要求你秘密接受任何事情，你的回答永远是：我当然愿意。所以我觉得在整集的这个过程中，当帕姆和德怀特一起演这出小戏时，她其实在想象自己以后要怎么把这一切统统告诉吉姆。哦，肯定的。肯定的。好吧，这是德怀特心目中的团队。德怀特是地区经理。德怀特也是助理地区经理。安迪是他的副手，因为这出于政治考量。帕姆是地区经理的秘密助理。而且你猜怎么着？在一个被删减的场景中，我们发现安吉拉是负责监视地区经理秘密助理的间谍。
to the regional manager. Oh, and what does that mean? Well, as soon as Pam says, yeah, absolutely I do and agrees to be the secret assistant to the regional manager, she leaves. And when she does, the scene plays out. Dwight calls Angela and says, keep an eye on Pam. And Angela's like, done. And then immediately, my little head pops over the partition between accounting and reception. And I just start spying on you. Oh, that's amazing. I'm watching you. I'm watching you. Oh, I wish they'd left that in. I know. It's a fun detail, right? I love that detail. Well, now, lady, we go back to
哦，那意味着什么？好吧，就在帕姆说完“是的，我当然愿意”并同意担任地区经理的秘密助理后，她就离开了。当她离开时，接下来的戏是这样的。德怀特打电话给安吉拉，说：盯紧帕姆。安吉拉说：没问题。然后立刻，我的小脑袋从会计部和前台之间的隔板后面冒了出来。然后我就开始监视你了。哦，太棒了。我在看着你。我在看着你。哦，真希望他们把这段保留下来。我知道。这是一个有趣的细节，对吧？我太喜欢这个细节了。好吧，现在，女士们，我们回到
corporate and Michael's interview has begun. Andy Buckley is so fantastic in this scene. I mean, Steve is always fantastic. But to watch Steve as Michael because Michael's so ridiculous, play off someone who's so believably a corporate person. It just was so fun to watch. So my favorite part of this scene with David and Michael is when he asks Michael where he sees room for improvement. And Michael's suggestion is that they rename the company altogether. Here, do you know his three names, right? His three suggestions?
总部，迈克尔的面试开始了。安迪·巴克利在这个场景里表现得太棒了。我是说，史蒂夫一直都很棒。但看史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔——因为迈克尔实在是太荒谬了——与一个如此令人信服的总部高管对戏，看这个过程真的太有趣了。所以我和大卫以及迈克尔这场戏里我最喜欢的部分是，大卫问迈克尔他觉得哪里有改进的空间。而迈克尔的建议竟然是他们干脆把公司名字改了。来，你知道他的三个名字，对吧？他的三个建议？
I wrote them down. Yeah. Here are the names. Paper great. Great papers are passion. We're great. Super duper paper or just super duper. Yeah. Any of those. Any of those could work. Well, we had a fan question from Rebecca W. She said, were the suggestions Michael gave for a change of name of the company improvised? I checked the script. They were all in there with the exception of super duper paper and super duper. Those were. But there was also way more to this interview scene. And I have to ask you, Angela, are they in the deleted scenes because they were so funny?
我都记下来了。是的。名字是这些。伟大的纸张。伟大的纸张就是激情。我们很伟大。超级无敌纸张，或者干脆叫超级无敌。是的。这几个都行。这些名字哪个都行。好吧，我们收到了来自丽贝卡·W的粉丝提问。她说，迈克尔提出的更改公司名称的建议是即兴发挥的吗？我查了剧本。除了“超级无敌纸张”和“超级无敌”之外，其他的都在剧本里。不过这场面试戏其实还有更多内容。我不得不问你，安吉拉，它们在删减片段里吗？因为实在是太搞笑了。
There are so many deleted scenes for this particular episode. And this scene has several and they are hilarious. One of my favorite ones is that David says, what do you see in the future? But he's meaning about the company. Where do you see the future going here? And Michael goes, he goes on about all this stuff. He goes on about how many kids he's going to have and all this stuff. But then he says, also, I think there could be one vitamin that you take for all of these other vitamins, but it's just one. I don't know. And David Wallace goes, you mean a multivitamin? And Michael's like, I don't know what they're going to call it. I don't know. It is so funny, but they're great deleted scenes for this
这一集有好多好多的删减片段。而这个场景就有好几个，真的笑死人了。我最喜欢的其中一个片段是，大卫问，你对未来有什么看法？但他是指关于公司的未来。你觉得这里的未来会走向何方？结果迈克尔滔滔不绝地说了一大堆有的没的。他讲了他以后打算生多少个孩子之类的一大堆。但接着他说，还有，我觉得可以有一种复合维生素，你吃这一种就能顶替所有其他的维生素，就一颗。我不知道。然后大卫·华莱士说，你是说复合维生素吗？迈克尔就说，我不知道他们会管这叫什么名字。我不知道。这一段真的太搞笑了，不过这一集有很多超棒的
episode. That multivitamin thing was in the script and it made me laugh out loud when I read it. It is hilarious. He's like, I don't know what they're going to call it, but that's the idea. And David Wallace's look to him is just like, okay. And he's like, thanks for coming in, Michael. So, you know, Michael feels like he's had a pretty great interview. He's on his way out and he says, oh, you should know that Jan and I are dating again. So I'm going to need to fill out one of those love documents. And David Wallace is like, well, you should know that this job you're interviewing for
删减片段。那个复合维生素的梗本来就在剧本里，我读到的时候直接笑出声了。太搞笑了他当时说，我不知道他们会给它起名叫什么，但这就是我的想法。而大卫·华莱士看他的眼神就像是在说，好吧。然后大卫说，谢谢你来面试，迈克尔。所以，你知道的，迈克尔觉得自己面试表现相当不错。他在离开的路上说，哦，你该知道我和简又开始约会了。所以我需要去填一份那种恋爱关系申报表。大卫·华莱士就说，嗯，那你应该知道你这次面试的职位其实是要取代简的。我当时脑子里唯一想到的就是：不，你不能把这种信息告诉迈克尔。
is to replace Jan. And all I could think of was like, no, you can't tell Michael this kind of information. There is no way this man can hold on to that. You know what it made me think of Angela is when he says I need to sign another one of those love documents, I was like, it reminded me in dinner party when Michael explains he's had a vasectomy but then had it reversed and then had a vasectomy and reversed. I was like, how many of these documents have they been signing? It's like, we're on, we're off, we're on, we're off. And I wonder also if they had dramatic ripping in half of the document.
这个男人绝对守不住这种秘密。你知道这让我想起了什么吗，安吉拉？当他说需要去签另一张那种恋爱关系申报表时，这让我想起在《晚宴派对》那一集里，迈克尔解释说他做了输精管切除术，然后又做手术接通了，然后又做了输精管切除术又接通了。我就想：他们到底签过多少次这种表格了？感觉就是：我们在一起了，我们分了，我们在一起了，我们分了。而且我也在想，他们会不会把这份文件戏剧性地撕成两半。
Yes. I have so many questions about the love document, but I agree with you. This news to Michael that the job he's applying for is Jan's job and she doesn't know yet that she's going to be let go. This is a secret that you should not allow Michael to hold. You can't tell Michael any secret. You couldn't say, hey, don't tell anyone, but I have toe fungus. Forget it. The next thing out of his mouth would be, I'm so sorry you have toe fungus in front of everyone. Yes.
是的。我对这张恋爱关系申报表有无数的问题，但我同意你的看法。这个消息对迈克尔来说简直是晴天霹雳——他申请的职位竟然是简的工作，而简现在还不知道自己要被炒鱿鱼了。这是一个绝对不能让迈克尔知道的秘密。你什么秘密都不能告诉迈克尔。你不可能跟他说：嘿，别告诉别人，但我有脚气。算了吧。他嘴里吐出的下一句话绝对就是：不好意思，大家看，他有脚气。是的。
Yes. I don't have toe fungus. I was just trying to think of something. I have fungus on my toenails. I know, but you treated it and it's all better. It came back. It did. Yeah. You know, if you wear nail polish long enough and your toenails don't get a good amount
是的。我其实没有脚气。我刚才只是随便想个例子。我脚趾甲确实有真菌感染。我知道，但你已经治疗过了，现在全好了。又复发了。确实。你知道的，如果你涂指甲油太久，而且你的脚趾甲没有获得充足的
of oxygen, you can get, you know, by the way, everyone, toe fungus is just like on your toenail. It's just like a little white spot. Yeah. That's what those white spots are, everyone. If you're like, what are these white spots on my toenails when I take off my nail polish? That's toe fungus, y'all. And you can get a special like oil and polish to put on there to get rid of it if you care. Well, my mom always would say, everyone's will just take your toenail polish off and let your toenails breathe.
氧气，你就会得，顺便说一句，各位，脚趾甲真菌感染其实就长在你的趾甲上。它就像一个小小白斑。是的，各位，那些白斑就是这么回事。如果你在卸掉指甲油时纳闷：我脚趾甲上的这些小白斑是什么呀？那就是脚趾甲真菌，各位。如果你介意的话，你可以买一种特殊的油和抛光剂涂在上面把它去掉。好吧，我妈妈总是说，大家时不时要把指甲油卸掉，让脚趾甲呼吸一下。
It's good advice. It's not pretty. You're going to have a week of like funky looking yellow toes. Sorry. All right. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Where are we? Well, we need to go back to Dunder Mithlin because Dwight would like everyone to gather in the conference room. He needs to discuss and introduce the Shrewtbuck reward system. That was so funny to me. You know what I loved about this? First of all, at 25 minutes, three seconds, Angela's so proud. She's so proud. She has this look.
这倒是个好建议。虽然不太好看。你得经历一个星期看起来奇奇怪怪的黄脚趾甲时期。抱歉。好吧。抱歉。抱歉。我们聊到哪儿了？好吧，我们得回到邓德米弗林，因为德怀特想让大家在会议室集合。他需要讨论并引入“施鲁特元”（Schrute Bucks）奖励系统。这真的太逗了。你知道我最喜欢什么吗？首先，在25分03秒，安吉拉一脸骄傲。她太骄傲了。她露出了那种表情。
Yes. Dwight is calling his first conference room meeting. She is, can't believe it. But I love how he leads everyone in. He's like, no more meetings, right? Michael had all these useless meetings. Instead, we're going to have lectures. Yes. And Pam, Pam can't wait. She's like, what is he going to do? I can't wait. I can't wait to see what's about to happen. Well, we get in there and we start getting our first lecture. And it is about the origin of papermaking. Yeah. He starts with a bunch of Tupperware tins full of soil, different types of soil.
是的。德怀特正在召开他的第一次会议室会议。她简直难以置信。但我喜欢他是怎么把大家都带进去的。他说：再也没有会议了，对吧？迈克尔以前开了那么多毫无用处的会议。相反，我们要上课。是的。而且帕姆，帕姆简直迫不及待。她心想：他到底要干嘛？我等不及了。我等不及要看接下来会发生什么了。好吧，我们进去了，然后开始上第一课。内容是关于造纸术的起源。是的。
And he asked the question, what would you say is the most important element in the production of above ground leafy growth? You probably think it's phosphorus. And then Angela secretly shakes her head. No, I improvise that. And our camera operator caught it and was like, Oh, that's so good. Ken loved it. And he told me to keep doing it. Like I loved it. Like I obviously knew this speech that Dwight had practiced it for me. I used to love having those moments.
他拿出了好几个装满土壤的特百惠盒，里面是各种不同类型的土壤。然后他抛出一个问题：你们觉得在地上绿叶生长过程中，最重要的元素是什么？你们可能会觉得是磷。然后安吉拉偷偷摇了摇头。不，那是我的即兴发挥。我们的摄像师捕捉到了这一幕，然后说：哦，太棒了。肯非常喜欢。他让我继续这么演。就像我真的很喜欢那样——就像我显然知道德怀特为我排练过这段演讲一样。我以前超级喜欢那种时刻。
I'm sure he practiced it for you. And he's killing it. According to you, you're like, he's killing it, crushing it. By the way, the answer is nitrogen per Dwight. Lady, I had to know. Did you look it up? Did you look up phosphorus? You know that website Quora? Yeah, it's where you you post a question about something and then experts on that subject weigh in. Did you post the question? I didn't post the question. I got real excited.
我敢说他肯定为你排练过了。而且他表现超棒。按你的说法，他简直是全场最佳，帅呆了。顺便说一句，根据德怀特的说法，答案是氮。天哪，我必须知道。你查了吗？你查过磷了吗？你知道那个叫 Quora 的网站吗？对，就是你在上面发布一个关于某事的问题，然后该领域的专家会发表见解。你发问题了吗？我没有发问题。我当时超级兴奋。
But years ago, someone posted that exact question. The wording was exact. Exactly what Dwight says. There was an office fan years ago that was like, Wait, is this true? So it's really amazing, the back and forth from all the people who are not realizing that this is a direct quote from an office episode. It is just soil scientists weighing in. There's charts. There's pages and pages of these scientists debating what is the most important element in the production of above ground leafy growth. And the consensus is nitrogen.
但几年前，有人发布了那个一模一样的问题。措辞完全一样。和德怀特说的一模一样。几年前有一个办公室迷，当时就像是在想，等等，这是真的吗？所以真的很神奇，所有人都在那里争论不休，却没有意识到这是办公室某一集里的直接台词。里面全都是土壤科学家在发表见解。有图表。有整页整页的科学家在争论究竟什么才是地面以上叶片生长最重要的元素。大家的共识是氮。
How nitrogen way to go Dwight way to go. Jenna, do you remember filming the scene because I remember the smell? Can we talk about it for a second? We can. There was an earthy smell. Now, you know, this room had no real windows. So it's like sitting in a box. Now, it didn't didn't have a full ceiling, but we were sort of trapped in there with smells. Oh, yeah.
氮啊，真不愧是德怀特，干得漂亮。珍娜，你还记得拍这场戏的情景吗？因为我记得那股气味。我们能聊一会儿这个吗？可以。当时有一股泥土的芳香。现在，你知道的，这个房间没有真正的窗户。所以就像坐在一个盒子里。虽然没有完全封顶，但我们某种程度上被困在那些气味里了。哦，对。
And there was a real dirt smell. And then it's in the deleted scenes. You guys don't get to see it. But Dwight actually starts by dumping a whole bunch of trash on the table. I remember that. To talk to everyone about recycling. So we had some earthy trashy smells going. Yeah, it was intense. We also have the great moment, which is one of my favorite moments where Stanley does not want to participate. He won a Shrewt book, but he doesn't want it. No, he doesn't want it. He does not want to participate in any of this. And Dwight is
这里真的有一股泥土味。这部分在删减片段里。大家看不到了。但德怀特其实一开始是在桌上倒了一大堆垃圾。我记得这件事。为了和大家谈谈回收利用的事。所以我们当时搞了一些土里土气、垃圾味十足的东西。对，味道很浓烈。我们还有一个精彩的时刻，也是我最喜欢的时刻之一，斯坦利不想参与其中。他赢得了一本施鲁特书，但他不想要。不，他就是不想要。他不想参与任何这些事。德怀特
like, you don't want your Shrewt book. And he's like, no. And then he offers him like a thousand Stanley Nichols to leave him alone. A billion, a billion Stanley Nichols. If you never speak to me again. Yes, thank you. It's brilliant. And Dwight's response is he would like to know the conversion rate between Stanley Nichols and Shrewt books. And it's the same as leprechauns to unicorns.
就像是，你不想你的施鲁特书吗。他说，不。然后德怀特开出一千个斯坦利币让他别烦他。十亿，十亿个斯坦利币。如果你再也不跟我说话的话。是的，谢谢。这太绝了。德怀特的反应是他想知道斯坦利币和施鲁特书之间的汇率。结果这就跟小妖精对独角兽一样。
Yeah. And then, Jenna, you must have had so much fun because then everyone starts to be like, I'm out of here. I don't want to do this. And Pam is like, hey, pay attention. Lady, when I heard that delivery, now this was before I had children. But when I heard my voice, I was like, oh my gosh, that's the voice when I have to lay down the law with the kids. When I'm like, listen to me, I've asked three times to brush our teeth. It's time to brush teeth now. Hustle, go to the bathroom. I was like, oh my gosh, that is my mom voice.
对。然后，珍娜，你当时一定觉得太好玩了，因为接着大家开始纷纷表示，我才不干了。我不想做这个。然后帕姆就说，嘿，注意点。天哪，当我听到那个语气时，那还是在我生孩子之前。但当我听到自己的声音时，我心想，哦天哪，这不就是我跟孩子们立规矩时的语气吗。当我跟他们说，听着，我已经叫了三次去刷牙了。现在是刷牙时间。快点，去卫生间。我当时想，哦天哪，这就是我的“妈妈语气”。
That's my mom voice. My mom getting line voice. Yeah, that's right. Yeah. For sure. I was shocked. You had it in you all along. I did. It was meant to be.
这就是我的“妈妈语气”。我那种叫大家排好队的语气。对，没错。嗯，确实。我惊呆了。原来你骨子里一直都有这一面。我确实有。这就是命中注定。
Well, there's a nice little moment that I think Phyllis just improvised. And we often did things like this in the background. We just sort of made up our own story if we didn't have dialogue of how we would react to these moments. And she's sleeping. I know. 27 minutes, 29 seconds. I thought that was an amazing choice. Yeah. An amazing choice.
嗯，还有一个很棒的小片段，我觉得是菲利丝即兴发挥的。我们在背景里经常做这种事。如果我们没有台词来表达自己对这些时刻的反应，我们就会自己编造一个小故事。而她正在睡觉。我知道。27分29秒。我觉得这是一个绝佳的选择。对。一个绝佳的选择。
Well, listen, lady, we're about to go back to corporate. We're going to see Karen interview with David, but I think we should take a break. I think we should take a break and come back because Karen is crushing her interview. We need to get to it. She's doing really well. Yeah. All right, we'll be right back. Okay, we are back from break. Karen is being interviewed before we get into that. Jenna,
好了，听着，女士们，我们马上要切回总公司了。我们要看卡伦和戴维的面试，不过我觉得我们该休息一下了。我觉得我们应该休息一下再回来，因为卡伦的面试表现太惊艳了。我们得好好聊聊。她表现得真好。对。好的，我们马上回来。好的，我们休息回来了。在进入正题之前，卡伦正在接受面试，珍娜，
I had to look up the limelight one more time because I was pretty sure. And in fact, this is correct. There is a documentary about the history of the limelight, this huge part of New York's culture. I'm sorry to go on and on about it, but I think I want to watch this documentary. Number one, I will be watching that documentary tonight. Number two, you do not need to apologize for your interest in the limelight or for the interesting facts that you shared with us because lady, I want to say something. We got this really nice letter from a fan. And in it, she said, I just need to tell you that you guys do not need to apologize for
我不得不再次查了一下莱姆光夜总会，因为我当时挺确定的。事实上，这是对的。有一部纪录片讲的就是莱姆光夜总会的发展史，这是纽约文化中非常巨大的一部分。抱歉我一直在滔滔不绝，但我觉得我想看这部纪录片。第一，我今晚就要看那部纪录片。第二，你完全不需要为自己对莱姆光夜总会的兴趣道歉，也不需要为跟我们分享的这些有趣的事实道歉，因为女士，我想说点事。我们收到了一位粉丝发来的非常暖心的信。信里她说，我只是想告诉你们，你们真的不需要为
going off subject. You guys always apologize for it. And I love it. It's a great part of the podcast. And you know what, lady? It got me thinking. That is a thing. Hold on. Soapbox coming out. That is a very common thing that women do. Women apologize all the time for things they don't need to apologize about. And I think we do not need to apologize for our deep dives. We do not need to apologize for the things that interest us or for our banter that comes to us in the moment while making this podcast. I don't apologize. I like how by the end of that speech, you had like an affected way of talking. You're like, I don't apologize. I don't apologize for that either. Well, you know, that has been something
扯远了而道歉。你们总是为这个道歉。而我超喜欢这样。这是播客非常棒的一部分。你知道吗，女士？这让我陷入了思考。这真是一回事。等等。我要开始长篇大论了。这是女性非常常见的一种行为。女性总是为那些根本不需要道歉的事情不停地道歉。我觉得我们不需要为我们的深入探讨而道歉。我们不需要为我们感兴趣的事情道歉，也不需要为录制这个播客时当场迸发的闲聊道歉。我才不道歉。我喜欢你那段话说完时的语气，你说话的调子都变了。你说，我才不道歉。我才不为那个道歉呢。嗯，你知道的，这一直都是
I've sort of struggled with, I guess my whole life. I don't know. I think I used to say I'm sorry about everything. I don't know. Like I would say I'm sorry about the most ridiculous things. Like my chair would squeak. I'd be like, Oh, I'm sorry. Or I'd reach for a glass of water at the same time someone else would. I'd be like, Oh, I'm sorry. And um, yes, or like how many times have you been walking down the street and someone bumps into you and you say, Oh, sorry. What? I'm sorry for taking up the space. My body requires to walk down the street. You walked into me. Why am I apologizing? It's a thing that women do. We do. I mean, it's not just women, but there's this. I just I noticed it when we
我一直在纠结的事，我猜这几乎是我一辈子的心结吧。我不知道。我觉得我以前对什么事都说对不起。我不知道。比如我会为最荒谬的事情说对不起。比如我的椅子嘎吱作响，我就会说，哦，对不起。或者我和别人同时伸手去拿一杯水，我就会说，哦，对不起。还有，嗯，对啊，比如你在街上走着，有人撞到了你，你说，哦，对不起。什么？我为什么要为占据在街上走路所需的身体空间说对不起？是你撞到了我。我为什么要道歉？这是女性常做的事。我们确实会。我的意思是，不只是女性会这样，但有这么个现象。我只是——当我看到
got that nice letter. I thought, This is the coaching I needed. This is good. Well, I appreciate that letter. I think, I think I probably had read a comment that probably wasn't healthy where this guy said we talked about appetizers for eight minutes. Anyone to drive his car into a pole. And I was like, Oh, no, but you know what, you know what I want to say to that man? Listen, mister, I'm sorry. Sometimes we're going to talk about appetizers and we're going to talk about bars that used to be in a church and pockets and Clementine Paddleford. And you know what? I really want to encourage you to do with love. Hit fast forward. Angela, you are right. You don't have to listen to anything you don't want to, but we also
那封暖心的信时我注意到了。我想，这就是我需要的指导。这挺好的。嗯，我很感激那封信。我想，我大概之前读过一条不太健康的评论，有个男的说我们花了八分钟聊开胃菜。让人想把车开进电线杆。当时我想，哦，不，不过你知道吗，你知道我想对那个男人说什么吗？听着，先生，我很抱歉。有时候我们就是要聊开胃菜，我们要聊以前开在教堂里的酒吧，我们要聊口袋，还要聊克莱门蒂娜·帕德尔福德。你知道吗？我真的满怀爱意地鼓励你去做一件事。按快进键吧。安吉拉，你说得对。你不需要听任何你不想听的内容，但我们同样
get to talk about what we want. Right? Yeah. Without apology. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. And good day to you. And now Karen is crushing her interview. 28 minutes, 58 seconds. I thought she was going to get the job. Well, she should get the job. I mean, really, it was between her and Jim. I think it was theirs to lose. And David Wallace clearly has like a man crush on Jim. Well, we noticed this back when David threw his party and he wanted to go shoot hoops with Jim. I mean, I'm I don't want to get my soapbox out again so soon. But this happens in the male corporate culture. There's all these ways and activities that men have to bond between men. And it's been difficult for women to, you know, get in there. They've
有权谈论我们想谈的话题。对吧？对。无需道歉。对。谢谢。谢谢。祝您过得愉快。现在卡伦的面试表现太惊艳了。28分58秒。我当时以为她能得到这份工作。嗯，她确实该得到这份工作。我是说，真的，人选就是在她和吉姆之间。我觉得这工作本来就是他们的囊中之物。而且戴维·华莱士明显对吉姆有着某种“兄弟崇拜”。嗯，早在戴维办派对想和吉姆去投篮时我们就注意到了。我是说——我不想这么快又开始长篇大论。但这在男性企业文化中经常发生。男人们之间有很多建立关系的途径和活动。而女性很难融入其中，你知道的，他们有
got their golfing and they're shooting of the hoops. And, you know, yeah. Well, while this is going on, these interviews, I just said I was sorry to get out my soapbox. Oh my God, I did it again. I just apologized. I can't stop it. We can't stop it. We will stop. We'll try. We'll try. Okay. So listen, while Karen is interviewing, Michael goes to Jan's office. Nope. Nope. He should have just kept on walking. He immediately tells her that she's going to be fired. She's being replaced. So of course, Jan storms in to Karen's interview and starts yelling at him. She says, Hey, you son of a bitch. Like just right away. And David is so calm. We talked about this last week with Paul, where Paul really admired
高尔夫还有投篮。而且，嗯，对。好吧，就在这期间，在这些面试进行的时候，我刚刚才为了长篇大论而说了一声对不起。哦天哪，我又来了。我刚刚又道歉了。我根本停不下来。我们停不下来。我们会停的。我们会试着停下的。好吧。所以听着，在卡伦面试的时候，迈克尔走进了珍的办公室。不。不。他当时应该直接走开的。他一进去就直接告诉珍她要被解雇了。她被取代了。所以不出所料，珍气势汹汹地冲进卡伦的面试现场，开始冲他大喊大叫。她说，嘿，你这个王八蛋。一上来就这么说。而戴维却异常冷静。我们上周跟保罗聊过这个，保罗真的很佩服
David for being so pointed and calm during this moment. And he says, Jan, this is long overdue. Long overdue. You've shown no interest in your job lately. We can never get a hold of you. Very erratic behavior. Like, like your head's not here. You're not here. He calls her unstable. Yeah. And then Michael's like, you're unstable. And then David's like, I'm, I'm sorry. What? And Michael's like, never mind. We're all unstable. What's happening? Michael also insists he didn't tell her. Yeah. It wasn't me. While hiding behind the partition. I didn't say anything. Well, Jan asks if this is because of her new boobs. Because Michael loves them. And she doesn't care. Yeah. He loves them. That's all that
戴维在这个时候表现得那么直白和冷静。他说，珍，这早就该发生了。早就该发生了。你最近对工作毫无热情。我们永远都找不到你。行为非常反常。就像，就像你的心思不在这里。你根本不在状态。他称她为情绪不稳定。对。然后迈克尔就像是在说，你才不稳定。紧接着戴维说，我，抱歉。什么？然后迈克尔说，没关系。我们大家都不稳定。这都什么情况？迈克尔还坚称自己没有告诉她。对。不是我。同时躲在隔板后面。我什么都没说。好吧，珍质问这是否是因为她做了新胸部手术。因为迈克尔很喜欢。而她根本不在乎。对。他很喜欢。这才是
matters to her. Well, then she's being escorted out of the office. She's got a bunch of stuff. She hugs Hunter. Her whole scene with Hunter is brilliant. She's like, good luck with the band. Don't let them change you here. It's so good. Well, she drops a bunch of her stuff on the ground and Hunter and Michael are trying to help her pick it up. And lady, did you know that was not supposed to happen? I did know that. I did know that because they talked about it in the DVD commentary. Malora said she had this box full of like, what was Jan's belongings, right? And it was sort of a awkward, different shaped items and a few things spilled out. And Ken did not yell cut. He just let the scene play out. And Michael and Hunter,
对她最重要的。好吧，然后她被护送离开了办公室。她拿了一堆东西。她拥抱了亨特。她和亨特的那整场戏简直绝了。她说，祝你的乐队好运。别让他们在这里改变你。太精彩了。好吧，她把一堆东西掉在了地上，亨特和迈克尔赶紧帮她捡起来。而且女士，你知道这本来是不应该发生的吗？我确实知道。我当然知道，因为他们在DVD评论音轨里聊过。梅洛拉说她当时拿了一个装满东西的盒子，里面装的是珍的私人物品，对吧？那里面全是一些形状尴尬、奇奇怪怪的物品，然后有几样东西洒了出来。而肯并没有喊停。他只是让戏继续演下去。迈克尔和亨特，
everyone just stayed in the moment. They're trying to help her put things back. And Malora said they actually had a hard time getting everything to fit back in. And that's why that played out so long. But everyone's reactions are perfect. David's like, what's happening? And then you have Jim and Karen. That was all unscripted. I love stuff like that. I love that. And you know, it reminds me, Angela, when I've had to do scenes where I have to carry a lot of stuff. A lot of times they'll give you like a suitcase that's empty, or they'll give you a bag and it doesn't really have much in it. And I had to shoot this scene where I was coming through the door and I had all this junk. And I said, will you make
所有人都依然留在戏里。他们试着帮她把东西捡起来。梅洛拉说他们其实费了好大劲才把所有东西重新塞回盒子里。这就是那场戏演了那么久的原因。但所有人的反应都太完美了。戴维的反应是，这什么情况？然后还有吉姆和卡伦。那全都是即兴发挥。我太喜欢这种桥段了。我太喜欢了。这让我想起，安吉拉，当我必须拍那些得搬很多东西的戏时。很多时候他们会给你一个空的行李箱，或者给你一个里面其实没装多少东西的包。我曾拍过一场戏，我要走进门里，拿了一堆乱七八糟的东西。我说，你们能把它弄得真实一点吗？因为我觉得，如果我真的是在吃力地拿著，如果我不是在假装吃力，效果就会好得多。我发誓，每次我拍这场戏时，总会有其他疯狂的事情发生。这比我假装要好得多。因为这些就是当下的时刻，对吧？这是一个现实生活中的真实时刻，每个人都顺其自然地演了下去。这真的太搞笑了。太搞笑了。不过你说得对。摄像机捕捉到的那些我们在假装演戏时的真实瞬间。我总会想起《老友记》里那个著名的场景，他们试图把沙发搬上楼梯间。罗斯大喊着，转向，转向。所有人都在抬着沙发。我太喜欢这些时刻了，
it real? Because I think that if I'm really struggling with it, if I'm not pretending to struggle with it, it'll just be better. And I swear every time I would do the scene, some other insane thing would happen. And it was so much better than if I was faking it. And so because these are the moments, right? This was a real life moment and everyone enrolled with it. And it was so funny. It's so funny. But you're right. Those real moments that the camera captures when we're playing make believe. I always think about that famous scene on Friends where they're trying to get that sofa up the stairwell. And Ross is yelling pivot, pivot. And they're all holding the sofa. Like these are these moments I love
因为它们就像真实的生活一样。不过梅洛拉确实说了一件事。她说，如果你注意看，如果你看这场戏，在我们弯腰捡东西并把它们放回盒子的整个过程中，你都看不到我的脸，因为我把腰弯到了极致。所以我的头发挡住了我的脸，因为我笑得太厉害了。我太喜欢这个了。我得回去再看一遍。嗯。好吧，接着迈克尔告诉戴维，嘿，有消息了通知我一声。等你知道结果了告诉我。戴维的反应是，你不会得到这份工作的。对。于是，理所当然地，迈克尔说，我撤回对自己的考量。
because it's like real life. But Milora did say one thing. She said, if you notice, if you watch the scene, the whole time we're picking up items and putting them back in the box, you do not see my face because I bent over as far as I could. So my hair would hide my face because I am laughing so hard. I love that. I'm going to go back and look at that. Yeah. Well, Michael then tells David, hey, just let me know about the job. Let me know when you know. David is like, you're not getting the job. Yeah. And so then, of course, Michael is like, I withdraw myself from consideration.
你接受我的撤回吗？戴维说，接受。哦天哪。哦天哪。然后迈克尔又说，那我还能保留我在斯克兰顿的工作吗？戴维说，可以。他接着说，太好了，因为这本来就是我唯一真正想要的。好吧，说到斯克兰顿，迈克尔回去可要大吃一惊了，因为安迪和德怀特正在把德怀特的办公室——也就是迈克尔的旧办公室、很快又会变成他的办公室的那间屋子——刷成黑色。他们把所有的墙都刷成了黑色。好吧，迈克尔肯定会被吓一跳，因为他在一个被删减的片段里还告诉过德怀特，出于某种哀悼，一个月内不要对我的办公室做任何改动，为了纪念我不在的日子，什么都别碰。而德怀特转头就开始把它刷成
Do you accept my withdrawal? David's like, yeah. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. And then Michael's like, but do I get to keep my job at Scranton? And David's like, yes. And he goes, good, because that's all I ever really wanted. Well, speaking of Scranton, Michael's going to be in for a surprise because Andy and Dwight are painting Dwight's new office, Michael's old office, soon to be office again, black. They're painting all the walls black. Well, Michael's going to be really surprised because he also in a deleted scene told Dwight, don't do anything to my office for one month out of sort of like mourning, like don't touch anything for one month to honor my absence. And Dwight immediately starts painting it
黑色了。我们收到了很多关于他们是怎么做到这一点的提问。他们并没有粉刷真正的墙。他们搬来了其他黑色的假墙。对。所以他们并没有粉刷迈克尔办公室原本的墙。他们做了道具墙。然后他们就能把墙拿下来。是的。而且墙就在后面。是的，非常轻松。但他们确实是在粉刷。对。而且他们在这场戏中一直在粉刷这些假墙的不同面板。不过，是的，要把它恢复成原本的迈克尔办公室非常容易。好吧，珍娜，回到纽约，有一件事我们还没聊到，那就是吉姆和卡伦对
black. We had a lot of questions about how we did this. They did not paint the real walls. They brought in other fake walls that were black. Yeah. So we did not paint the walls that were Michael's office. They made dummy walls. And then they could take them down. Yes. And the walls were right behind. Yes, very easily. But they were really painting. Yeah. And they had different panels of these fake walls that they would paint throughout this scene. But yeah, it was very easy to reset it back to the original Michael's office. Well, Jenna, back in New York, one of the things we didn't talk about was Jim and Karen's reaction to
珍彻底崩溃的反应。我的意思是，卡伦说，哇，这真的太自我毁灭了。而吉姆的反应是，我其实有点同情她。对。卡伦一点也不同情她。对。卡伦觉得，我不懂，她对吉姆没有丝毫同情。不。卡伦受够了。她受够了这些家伙。好吧，说到受够了，吉姆还得去参加他的面试。我觉得这挺有意思的。吉姆说，嘿，你知道的，如果你想先走，我可以，你知道的，待会儿再去找你。而卡伦顺水推舟地抓住了这个机会。她说，对啊，其实我想去市中心跟一些朋友吃午饭。你介意吗？拜拜。
Jan's big meltdown. I mean, Karen's like, wow, that was really self-destructive. And Jim is like, I kind of feel bad for her. Yeah. Karen does not feel bad for her. Yeah. Karen's like, I don't know. I think she's not having any sympathy for Jim. No. Karen is done. She is done with these folks. Well, speaking of done, Jim still has to go into his interview. And I thought this was interesting. Jim was like, hey, you know, if you want to take off, I can just, you know, meet you later. And Karen kind of jumps on it. She's like, yeah, actually, I wanted to meet some friends downtown for lunch. Do you mind? Bye.
我当时并没有——我并没有觉得这有什么奇怪的。但这看起来就像，你知道的，如果她只是坐在大厅里干等他，而且她确实有朋友在那儿吃饭，难道她就不能去见他们吗？然后他面试完再去找她？我不知道。我只是在想象，如果李和我去了纽约，我们俩都在同一栋大楼里参加一个重要的会议，而且我的会议先开始，他又得等我，我就会觉得，我会等你，这样我就会成为你开完会后看到的第一个人。然后你就可以把一切都告诉我。这太甜蜜了。这太甜蜜了。这太甜蜜了。这太甜蜜了。很显然，我的反应是，
Now I didn't, I didn't see that as like weird. But that seemed like what, you know, if she's just sitting in a lobby, just waiting for him and she does have friends who are eating, like, couldn't she go meet them? And then he come after? I don't know. I'm just imagining, like, if Lee and I had gone to New York and we were both going for an important meeting in the same building and my meeting was first and he had to wait for me, I would just be like, I'll wait for you so that I'm the first face you see after your meeting. And you can tell me all about it. That's so sweet. That's so sweet. That's so sweet. That's so sweet. Clearly, I'm like,
行，午饭时见。我吃我的慕斯去啦。拜拜。祝你好运，宝贝。床上一见。我不知道。我只是觉得，如果我没有什么必须去的地方。现在听着，我确实理解。她来纽约的时间很短。也许这是她见这些朋友的唯一机会。我是这么想的。我想，你知道的，她在那儿有平时根本见不到的朋友，他们说，等你面试完来跟我们吃午饭吧。然后她就想，哦天哪，行啊。但现在——现在珍经历了全面崩溃，也许事情——
okay, meet me for lunch. I'll be having my moussins. Bye. Good luck, babe. See you on the bed. I don't know. I just sort of like, if I don't have anywhere that I have to be. Now listen, I do get it. She's in New York for a brief period of time. Maybe this is her only chance to see these friends. That's what I thought. I thought, you know, she had friends there if she never gets to see and they're like, when you're done with your interview, meet us for lunch. And she's like, Oh my God, yeah. But now, now Jan has had this whole meltdown and maybe things,
面试的时间被稍微推迟了一点，她会错过午饭的。而我，也许吧。我不知道。不过我的意思是，想想看。我脑子里在提前脑补。所以现在等吉姆结束这个重要的面试时，他将无法单独和卡伦在一起。他得带着她去一家餐馆，面对她所有的朋友。面试怎么样？挺好。不过我们现在不能聊这个。
the timing of the interview has got pushed back a little and she's going to miss lunch. And I, Maybe. I don't know. But I mean, think about that. I'm like thinking forward. Like, so now when Jim gets out of this big interview, he's not going to have Karen alone. He has to walk into a restaurant with her and all her friends. And how'd your interview go? Good. We can't talk about it right now, though.
我不知道。这是一件大事。这是一场重要的面试。我觉得这中间需要有那种亲密的陪伴与支持。我不知道。好吧，他们显然不是天生一对。好吧，我不知道。我觉得帕姆会等的。我觉得帕姆也会等的。我不知道这到底是件好事还是坏事。而且我觉得珍娜·费舍尔也会等的。我也会等的。
I don't know. This is a big deal. It's a big interview. I think there's, there's room for like intimate support. I don't know. Well, they're clearly not meant to be together. Well, I don't know. I think Pam would have waited. I think Pam would have waited too. I don't know if that's a good thing or a bad thing. And I think Jenna Fisher would have waited. I would have waited too.
安吉拉持中立态度。安吉拉持中立态度。这得看是哪家餐馆，以及你有多想要这份工作。好吧，听着，现在镜头切到珍和迈克尔坐车回斯克兰顿的场景。天哪，这让我想起了珍在《鸡尾酒会》里的那个车内名场面。她在车里崩溃了，家人们。车和珍之间到底有什么魔咒？他们，你知道吗？是不是因为摄像机太小了，珍忘了他俩在镜头前，然后她把这当成了自己的忏悔室，
Angela's on the fence. Angela's on the fence. It depends on the restaurant and how bad you want the job. Well, listen, now we cut to the car ride back to Scranton with Jan and Michael. And lady, this reminded me of Jan's car moment in cocktails. She falls apart in a car ride, guys. What is it about car rides and Jan? They're, you know what? Is it because the cameras are tiny and Jan forgets that she's on camera and she, this is like her confessional is
也就是车里？关于珍的最好笑的桥段都发生在车里。我觉得这是情侣间常有的事。我真的这么觉得。因为我觉得你在派对、学校集会、足球赛或者在宜家购物时，无论你在哪儿，只要状况发生了，你都会强忍着。你把情绪憋在心里，然后一上车，要么你们俩开始互撕，要么你们开始大笑，要么其中一个人哭了出来。这就是那种让你觉得，天哪，的时刻。你说得对。
the car? Best stuff comes from Jan in a car. I think it's a couples thing. I really do. Cause I think you hold it together while you're at the party or the school assembly or the soccer match or shopping at IKEA, wherever you are and something goes down. You hold it in and then you get in the car and then you either let each other have it or you start laughing or one of you cries. Like that's the moment where you're like, oh my God. You are right.
我们以前。对。我刚开始在喜剧界发展时有一群朋友，如果我们在外面看到某对情侣在酒吧或者其他地方有点闹别扭的迹象，我们大家就会悄悄耳语：车上见，车上见。这下回家有得受了。我太喜欢了。我对车里的珍百看不厌。看不够。她开始哭了。她说，都是这些止疼药害的。他们在我做完隆胸手术后给我的，然后她又说，哦等等，这倒行得通。她的情绪
We used to. Yes. I had a group of friends when I was like starting out here in comedy and like if we were out somewhere and we saw a couple kind of have a little tiff moment, like at a bar or something, we'd all whisper car ride home, car ride home. Like it is not going to go well. Well I love it. I can't get enough of Jan in the car. I can't get enough. She starts crying. She's like, it's these painkillers. They gave me after my boob job and then she's like, oh wait, this could work. Like her emotions are
起起伏伏。她说我可以穿着紧身裤，等着你在五点十五分回家。对。她主动提出要搬去和迈克尔同居。对。而迈克尔的反应是，什么？哦，好吧，他，拜托。他是自己挖坑把自己埋了。他说，我想你是可以搬进我和我的公寓里。我想我是能把房子拿回来。我大概会在我的eBay账号上收到一个差评。但这就好像在这集的开头，他请求所有的女士帮他不要和珍
going up and down. She's like, I could wear stretch pants and wait for you to come home at five 15. Yes. She invites herself to move in with Michael. Yeah. And Michael is like, what? Oh, well he, come on. He walked himself into that. He's like, I guess you could move in with me and my condo. I guess I could get it back. I'd probably get a negative review on my eBay account. But it's like at the beginning of this episode, he asks all of the ladies to help him not get
复合，而结局却是他们同居了。对。而且她没有工作，整个人正在走向崩溃。这信息量太大了。好吧，迈克尔回到了办公室。他宣布自己退出了竞选。他注意到自己的办公室现在被刷成了黑色。我挺喜欢这个桥段的。他让瑞恩去给他买杯咖啡，而瑞恩说他再也不干那种差事了。接着迈克尔说，不，是给我买。笨蛋。
back together with Jan and it ends with them moving in together. Yeah. And she doesn't have a job and she's spiraling. That's a lot. Well, Michael comes back into the office. He announces he has withdrawn his name from contention. He notices that his office is now painted black. I liked this bit. He tells Ryan to go get him a coffee and Ryan said he doesn't do that stuff anymore. And he says, no, it's for me. Bimbo. Kids.
小屁孩。对。我知道。哦，瑞恩的的高光时刻要来了。而就在这时，帕姆问，卡伦拿到工作了吗？嗯。对。不知道。有人好奇得很呢。迈克尔在这里发表了一番可以说是让人心碎的演讲。
Yeah. I know. Oh, Ryan is about to have his moment. And this is when Pam asks, did Karen get the job? Hmm. Yeah. I don't know. Someone's real curious. Michael has a whole speech here that is sort of heartbreaking.
他说，好吧，所以我哪儿也不去，永远也不会离开。这个地方将成为我出生的医院、我的家、我的养老院、埋葬我骨骸的墓地，镜头扫过每个人的脸。就像是，这对谁都不是个好消息。对，确实如此。然后德怀特回到了他的办公桌前。这是一个温馨的时刻。我喜欢帕姆和德怀特之间这些温馨的时刻，他感谢帕姆以极大的尊严履行了职责，她向他敬礼，他也回敬了一个军礼。对。这有点像是他们版本的空中击掌。
He says, yeah, so I'm going nowhere, never going to leave. This place is going to be the hospital where I was born, my house, my old age home, my graveyard for my bones and the camera pans across everyone's faces. Like, this isn't good news for anybody. Yeah, it's true. And then Dwight's back at his desk. This is a sweet moment. I love these sweet moments between Pam and Dwight where he thanks Pam for serving with great dignity and she salutes him and he salutes her back. Yeah. It's kind of their version of the air high five.
好吧，你知道的，德怀特后来甚至说帕姆是他最好的朋友。对。你知道的，太甜了。好吧，这是大多数人可能都没注意到的一幕，但在35分34秒时，背景里的会计部门，当迈克尔说他回来了，然后做那些奇怪的举动时，凯文即兴发挥了这样一个时刻，他就像是在说，我回来了。对。
Well, you know, Dwight goes on to say eventually that Pam is his best friend. Yeah. You know, it's so sweet. Well, this is something that probably most people didn't catch, but at 35 minutes, 34 seconds in the background and accounting, Brian is Kevin sort of improvises this moment when Michael's saying that he's back and he's like doing all that weird stuff. He's like, I'm back. Right.
没错。没错。这太棒了。我回来了。总之，凯文倾身对安吉拉说，布莱恩是即兴发挥的这个。他说，所以，等等，我得拿到工作，而我只是摇头说不。你听不清他在说什么。我只是想起了这些诸如此类的小细节。我们当时就在后面演我们自己的戏。
Yes. Yes. It's good. I'm back. Anyway, Kevin sort of leans over to Angela and Brian improvised this. He was like, so wait, I need to get the job and I just shake my head. No. And you can't hear what he's saying. I just remembered these little moments like that. And we just were having our own scene back there.
我太喜欢这些了。我们一直在演戏。你永远不知道摄像机拍到了什么。你永远不会知道。好吧，现在我们来到吉姆的面试。他稳操胜券。戴维·华莱士对他赞不绝口。对。我的意思是，戴维·华莱士本该在面试一开始就说你被录用了。戴维·华莱士本该在面试一开始就说，你愿意做我的好朋友吗？真的太对了。每个人都想成为吉姆的好朋友。
I love those. We're always acting. You never know what the camera is getting. You never know. Well now we go to Jim's interview. He's a shoe in. David Wallace is like falling all over him. Yeah. I mean, David Wallace should have started the interview by saying you're hired. David Wallace should have started the interview by saying, will you be my best friend? It's so true. Everybody wants Jim to be their best friend.
他是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。他是个很好的好朋友。对。他是个了不起的人。对。所以戴维问了他几个问题，他说，你最喜欢什么？你最喜欢斯克兰顿办公室的什么？就在这时，吉姆打开了他的小文件夹，里面有一张来自帕姆的鼓励便签，
He's a very likable guy. He's a good best friend. Yeah. He's a great guy. Yeah. So David's asking him a few questions and he says, what is your favorite thing? What do you like most about the Scranton office? And it's right at this moment that Jim opens up his little folder and there is like a note of encouragement from Pam along with a little
还有她在办公室奥运会后一直珍藏着的酸奶盖。你知道那张便签对我说什么吗？什么？我会一直等你的面试结束。我才不会跑去和朋友吃什么酒肉午餐呢。没错。谢谢你。安吉拉，谢谢你。你很重要，发生在你身上的事对我来说也很重要。
yogurt lid that she has saved since office Olympics. You know what that note says to me? What? I would have waited for you until after your interview. I wouldn't have gone and met my friends for a boozy lunch somewhere. Exactly. Thank you. Angela, thank you. You matter and what happens to you matters to me.
对。吉姆看着那个便签，他说他最喜欢斯克兰顿办公室的是这里的友谊。就在这时，戴维问他，你觉得十年后的自己在哪里？好吧，吉姆这下有点慌了。他本来准备好了所有的答案，我确信他为这场面试做过准备，但现在帕姆和他在一起。对。然后镜头闪回海滩。
Yeah. And Jim looks at that and he says his favorite thing about the Scranton office were the friendships. And that's when David asks him, where do you see yourself in 10 years? Well, Jim is rattled now. He had all these answers ready to go. I'm sure he had prepared for this interview, but now Pam is there with him. Yeah. And we flash back to the beach. And we hear Jim tells Pam why he left Scranton. He acknowledges he's never really come back. And then Pam, talk about some PAM sass. I thought this was super ballsy. She's like,
我们听到吉姆告诉帕姆他离开斯克兰顿的原因。他承认自己其实从未真正离开过。然后帕姆——说到帕姆的毒舌。我觉得这真的超级有种。她说，
well, I wish you would. Yeah. Well, now we sort of hear Jim's interview. We hear like he's distracted. He's making jokes. We cut to a PAM talking head where she explains she hasn't really heard anything. Jim probably got the job. You know, there's no reason for him not to get the job. And she's she's really like, you can see her trying to process it and stay really positive. She's all day. She's been trying to stay really positive about this and convincing herself that her and Jim are friends. This is in the past. The beach was just closure. That was
嗯，我希望你能留下。对。好吧，现在我们算是听到了吉姆的面试过程。我们听到他心不在焉。他在开玩笑。镜头切到一个帕姆的独白画面，她解释说她其实什么都没听到。吉姆大概率拿到工作了。你知道的，他没有理由拿不到工作。而她真的——你能看出她一直在努力消化这一切，并努力保持积极乐观。她整整一天都在努力对此保持乐观，并说服自己她和吉姆只是朋友。这已经成了过去式。海滩上的那场对话只是个了结。那只是个
closure. And, you know, she says, we just never got the timing right. And that's okay. And then Jim walks in the room. I mean, she's so surprised to see him. Yeah. He interrupts the talking head and asks her if she wants to have dinner. She says, yeah. And then he's like, it's a date. Jenna, many, many people have talked about how great you are in that moment. And you are, you are, you are so good in that moment. So many emotions go across your face and your eyes tear up. Ken Quapas said you made him cry. Well, here's the thing. I owe that moment to Ken Quapas. And I'll tell you why. A lot of people wrote in and wanted to know what was going through my head during that scene
了结。而且，你知道的，她说，我们只是从未在对的时间遇到对的人。没关系的。然后吉姆走进了房间。我的意思是，她看到他简直惊呆了。对。他打断了独白，问她想不想一起吃晚餐。她说，好啊。然后他说，这是一场约会。珍娜，许许多多的人都说过你在那个时刻的表现有多棒。而你真的，真的很棒。那一刻，你表现得太出色了。无数的情绪掠过你的脸庞，你的眼眶湿润了。肯·夸帕斯说你让他哭了。好吧，事情是这样的。我要把那个时刻归功于肯·夸帕斯。我来告诉你为什么。很多人写信来想知道当我终于被吉姆约出去时，我脑子里在想什么。这太疯狂了，因为肯·夸帕斯，他就像是我们大家的父亲一样，对吧？安吉拉，当他上播客时，他解释说他的技巧就是用爱来激发出演员最好的状态。他是一个非常温和、善良的灵魂。他真的，真的太善良了。光是想想我就要哭了。我觉得，虽然我不确定，但我觉得那条我们是一条过。我想你看到的正是第一条拍摄的素材，因为我们当时已经和摄像机沟通好了，什么时候要推近，什么时候要切回我这里。所以在那一刻，当摄像机切回我身上时，我
when Jim finally asked him out. It's, it's crazy because Ken Quapas, he was a type of father figure to us, right? Angela, when he was on the podcast, he explained that his technique is to love people into their best work. He's just a very gentle, kind soul. He's so, so kind. I'm going to cry just thinking about it. I think, and I don't know, but I think we got that on the first take. I think what you are watching is the first take because we had kind of planned it out with the camera when it was going to swish over and when it was going to come back to me. So in that moment, when the camera swishes back to me, I was
其实正看着肯·夸帕斯，他眼里含着泪水，这让我情不自禁地也眼眶湿润了。我们只是分享了这样一刻——这个角色一路走来的心路历程在这里得到了私密的共鸣，他看着我的微笑，就像一个父亲在为你感到骄傲时露出的微笑。听着，如果肯·夸帕斯含着泪水微笑着看着我，我当场就会融化，因为这就好像你的爸爸那样看着你。对。对。就像你做到了，孩子。你做到了。对。对。我甚至不确定换作任何别的导演，能不能呈现出那种表演。哦，我觉得不可能。我的意思是，那是我和肯之间的一个时刻。那里面包含了太多我和肯·夸帕斯在这部剧里相伴的
actually looking at Ken Quapas and he had tears in his eyes and that made me tear up. And we just shared this moment, this, this private moment of acknowledgement for this journey of this character and he smiled at me in a way that a parent smiles at you when they're proud of you. Listen, if Ken Quapas looked at me with tears in his eyes smiling, I would disintegrate because he's just, it's like your dad looking at you like that. Yes. Yes. Like you did it, kiddo. You did it. Yes. Yes. And I don't even know if that performance could have been there with any other director. Oh, I don't think so. I mean, that was a moment between Ken and I. That was about so much about my
私人旅程。从第一天开始。嗯，那是一个非常、非常美好的时刻。我有一个问题要问你和所有的粉丝。什么？吉姆这混蛋居然把卡伦留在纽约了？他们是一起去的。他一个人开车回来的。搞什么鬼？好吧，我来告诉你。所以首先，其实剧本里关于这集的结局有两个版本。一个版本就是吉姆打断我独白的这个版本。还有一个版本，我们其实拍了。剧本上写着两个版本都拍。这不在删减片段里。那是什么？好吧，它不在删减片段里，但我们拍了。所以在第二个版本里，
personal Jenna journey with Ken Quapas on this show. From the very first day. Yeah. Well, it was a beautiful, beautiful moment. And I have one question for you and all the fans out there. What? Did Jim freaking leave Karen in New York? They rode together. He drove back alone. What the F? Well, I'll tell you. So first of all, there were actually two versions in the script for the ending of this episode. There was this version with Jim interrupting my talking head. And then there was a second version, which we shot. And in the script, it says shoot both versions. It's not in the deleted scenes. What is it? Okay, it's not in the deleted scenes, but we shot it. So in the second version, you
你可以听到吉姆在跟戴维面试时搞砸的画外音，甚至更夸张。就像他一直在开玩笑。他一点也没有把面试当回事，以至于戴维实际上都说出了口：你到底想不想要这份工作？哦，那会让我觉得很不舒服。对，那比你看到的版本还要过分一点。与此同时，所有这些发生的时候，你看到帕姆下班离开。她没有独白。她就是下班离开。她走进电梯。她坐电梯下楼。然后当电梯门打开时，吉姆正站在那儿。她说，你回来了。他说，对，你想去吃晚饭吗？帕姆说，好啊，我想去。然后她走出电梯，
hear voiceover of Jim throwing his interview with David, but it's even more. It's like he's really cracking jokes. He's not taking it seriously at all to the point that David actually says, do you even want this job? Oh, that would have made me uncomfortable. Yeah, it really tips it a little bit more than what you see. Meanwhile, while all that's happening, you see Pam leaving for the day. She doesn't do a talking head. She's just leaving for the day. She gets in the elevator. She goes down the elevator. And then when the elevator doors open, Jim is standing there. And she says, you're back. And he says, yeah, do you want to go to dinner? And Pam says, yeah, I do. And she walks out of the elevator
吉姆把镜头推回电梯里。随着电梯门缓缓关上，他们一起走开，他搂着她的肩膀，相视微笑。哦，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，我不喜欢这样。我不喜欢。我还是喜欢现在播出的这个版本。好吧，我和戴夫·罗杰斯核实过，他说那个场景确实存在，那是另一个备选版本。他说，我把那个保存在档案里。他说，我想我们有时可以把它放出来。如果你想看的话可以看到。但他也说过，那个版本从来没有、从来没有进入过正片。他们一直用的都是你现在看到的那个版本。他们只会把备选版本放给别人看。所有人都投票选了你现在看到的版本。不过他们当时还在纽约拍了另一个结局，
and Jim pushes the camera back into the elevator. And as the doors are closing, they walk off together and he puts his arm around her and they smile at each other. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't like it. I don't like it. I like the way it is. Well, I touched base with Dave Rogers, who said that that scene exists, that alternate. He's like, I have that in an archive. He's like, I think we should throw that up sometime. You could see it if you want. But he also said that it was never ever part of the cut of the show. They always had the one in that you see now. And then they would play the alternate for people. Everyone voted for what you see. But they also shot in New York, an
也就是你看到卡伦在哭，因为吉姆和她分手了。我敢说戴夫·罗杰斯一定有那个片段。我脑补戴夫·罗杰斯有一个硬盘和一个保险库，就像《碟中谍》一样。伴随着各种密码和机关。因为他手里握着一些非常重磅的《办公室》素材。好吧，听着，现在我们知道了到底是谁得到了这份工作。我们知道不是吉姆。我们知道不是迈克尔。我们本以为是卡伦。但你猜怎么着？另一个人参加了面试，而且他有MBA学位。
ending where you see Karen crying because Jim broke up with her. And I'm sure Dave Rogers has that. I picture Dave Rogers having this hard drive and a vault and it's like Mission Impossible. It's like ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. With all these codes and traps, because he's holding on to some serious office footage. Well, listen, now we find out who does get the job. We know it's not Jim. We know it's not Michael. We're assuming it's Karen. But guess what? Someone else interviewed and they had an MBA.
对，一个未知的MBA。工商管理硕士，对吗？不知道。不确定。工商管理硕士，A开头的某个学位。家人们，是瑞恩。临时工瑞恩再也不会给你倒咖啡了。他要去总公司了。
Yes, an unknown MBA. Masters of Business Administration, is that right? Don't know. Not sure. Masters of Business, something with an A. Guys, it's Ryan. Ryan the temp will not be getting your coffee anymore. He's going to corporate.
好吧，我们上周跟保罗聊过这个，因为很多人想知道为什么瑞恩能得到这份工作？你知道吗，女士，戴夫·罗杰斯告诉我，他们确实拍了一个备选场景，是卡伦得到了这份工作。场景是她在纽约哭了，然后电话响了，他们录用了她。所以我只是觉得，他们为这个盛大的大结局留下了这么多备选方案，真的非常、非常有趣。我想也许在某些情况下，他们还在争论到底谁该得到这份工作，吉姆和
Well we talked about this last week with Paul because a lot of people wanted to know why does Ryan get the job? And you know lady, Dave Rogers told me they did shoot an alternate scene where Karen gets the job. Where she's crying in New York and then the phone rings and they offer her the job. So I just think it's a very, very interesting how they left options on the table for this big finale. I think maybe in some cases they were still debating who gets the job, how do Jim and
帕姆到底该怎么走到一起？好吧，是的，看起来他们想给自己留一些选择，但我们也知道当时的情况，那就是拉什达接下了《公园与游憩》的角色。她要去拍那部剧了，所以第一，他们需要让吉姆和帕姆最终在一起而没有任何干扰，第二，拉什达也接到了一份很棒的新工作。对，所以她不能去总公司做迈克尔的上司了。对。她要去《公园与游憩》剧组了，而且我觉得有很多剧情的结局
Pam get together? Well yeah, it seems like they wanted to give themselves some choices but we also know what was going on at this time which is that Rashida booked her role on Parks and Rec. And she was going to be starting that job so A, they needed you know, finally Jim and Pam to be together without any kind of distraction and also Rashida just got a great new job. Yeah, so she can't be Michael's boss at corporate. No. She's going to be over at Parks and Rec and I think there were a lot of story endings
都有收尾部分，但因为这一集内容实在太庞大了而未能播出。我最喜欢的其中一个场景是珍搬家的画面。那是搬家日，有一辆搬货卡车，还有几个搬家工人在公寓前听从她的吆喝指挥，而迈克尔在一旁惊恐地看着这一切。他就像是在说，哦该死，我都干了些什么？这真是一个超棒的场景。哦天哪。他们不得不租下那个外景地拍了那场戏，结果它甚至都没有剪进
that had wrap ups that didn't make it to air because it was such a big episode. One of them I loved was there's a scene where Jan is moving in. It's moving in day, there's a moving truck, there's like guys and she's barking orders at them in front of the condo and Michael's just watching it all in horror. He's like, oh crap, what have I done? And it's such a good scene. Oh my gosh. They had to rent that location and shoot that scene and then it didn't even make it in the
正片里。对，我知道，我懂，不过天哪，这绝对为后面的好戏做好了铺垫，比如《晚宴派对》。哦对，晚宴派对。我太期待那一集了。我太期待第四季了。我刚刚看了《晚宴派对》的NG花絮，看得我兴奋极了，因为我们当时笑得前仰后合。哦，我已经迫不及待要聊那一集了。
episode. Yeah, I know, I know but boy is it going to set up some good stuff like dinner party. Oh yes, dinner party. I am so excited for that episode. I'm so excited for season four. I just watched the dinner party bloopers and it got me so excited because we laughed our butts off. Oh I can't wait to talk about it.
好吧，家人们，这就结束了第三季，我们很快就会带着第四季和大家见面，empat。那是印尼语里的“四”，katra。那是法语里的“四”。你想让我用西班牙语说“四”吗？当然。Quatro。Empat, quatro, katra。我法语发音对吗？
Well guys, this rounds out season three and we will see you soon with season four, empat. That's four in Indonesian, katra. That's four in French. Do you want me to say four in Spanish? Sure. Quatro. Empat, quatro, katra. Did I say it right in French?
对的。那是罗马数字里的“四”。我们第四季（empat）见。拜拜，家人们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布巴科夫。
You did. That's four in Roman numerals. See you in season empat. Bye guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow.
是的，那是罗马数字的四。第二季再见。再见，各位。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由厄尔文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。